luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and you guys have seen me build
a lot of cabins and bushcraft shelters
over the years you guys have seen me
build log cabins
floating cabins
and even lego cabins but now i'm gonna
take my family camping to the woods for
three days and we're gonna build a cabin
using cling wraps and it's gonna be fun
you guys are gonna enjoy this
[Music]
all right guys you ready to go camping
yeah
hey guys we're here we're doing
something a little different today i've
got my extended family with me and we've
got a pretty big group and we're gonna
be camping for three days
got the tent up but i don't think it's
in a great spot
looks like the water's been pooling here
when it rains i'm gonna move it up to
higher ground
all right i think we should get a fire
going
got a campfire going oh let's check this
out do a little tour
all right my sister's over here with her
awning doing some writing eye editing
i've got a book coming out next week so
all right i gotta get it done
we got three different campsites and
about 16 different family members coming
so it's gonna be a bit of a full house
let's go out on over here oh you got
tied to a tree
well you have to stay there until the
bears get you or until you learn to
behave
all right we need to start getting
dinner ready and i'm going to be making
pizza over the campfire here so need to
get some dough ready
on either side
there we go we got the pizza sandwiched
between two cookie trays with a couple c
clamps now we're gonna cook it if you're
wondering where i learned to cook
did you bring french dip sandwiches
camping
yeah well you got you got a little aju
sauce right there
over the campfire my mom doesn't even
like camping that much
you know for example or it's all a house
a car i know it's ours but i don't care
who you don't want to get a time you can
download a prize card but i mean that's
great
[Music]
so i burned this a little bit but that's
that's okay we're just going to pick a
little bit of the burn part off it's
still good
don't laugh it's still good
because yeah such nice get in here
evil yeah
[Music]
this one's looking a lot better here
yeah that looks a lot better yeah i mean
ah
we gotta get this dialed in
[Music]
looking at and saying like
there we go we got one right look at
that
i know you guys like the cheese
here's here's a little one right here
look how little that is
it's just a wee bit of pizza
you'll hardly notice it going down like
one sure they're only small no no i'm
glad you do like after we won
yeah not too bad i'm getting it dialed
in this is like pizza number seven hey
melanie what do you got there tater tots
with smoked sausage and cheese
just throw it over fire and heat up
all right i'm just gonna go ahead and
mix up some bread dough tonight so we
can have it for breakfast in the morning
all right we got a big thing of dough
we're just gonna let that sit till
morning
all right we're gonna do a little
dessert
all right guys we're gonna have roasted
strawberries dipped in marshmallow fluff
okay
here will you hold it for me
you know you should cover your
strawberry marshmallow
no more ice cream
i love it it's really good let's go pick
one
how was it that's why
this is what i'm into this is what i'm
like just rubbing it around
and then you can put it on it i buy some
marshmallows
not bad not bad
ah that's gonna be fun
you tell me when i want to take
well the kids are all full of pizza so
uh grandpa's gonna go take him in the
truck to go get ice cream
this campsite comes with babysitters it
really is glamping that's funny
do you guys get ice cream with grandpa
yes did you say thank you yes jacob you
like your ice cream
yes but
when you swim oh you dripped well i
swear more of that cone went on him
well it's getting late and time to get
the kids to bed got a couple hot water
bottles i'm gonna throw in their
sleeping bags get everyone nice and
toasty warm
there we go bottle from mama
just going and cleaning up the campsite
putting all the food in the cars
there's often bears around in these
campsites and we don't want to encourage
i them i love that
so
well it's late i gotta turn this camera
off and get the boys to bed but tomorrow
we're gonna start building our little
cabin all right i'll see you guys in the
morning
so
this is
try that
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
well breakfast was a success so i need
to go build a cabin now i need a place
to sleep tonight
we're gonna do a bunch of lashings and
i'm gonna use this small roller of
stretch wrap
all right i think the first thing i'm
gonna build in this cabin is a cot
jacob
i want to make sure my cod is wide
enough and long enough so i'm going to
use the mat as a template
they
know questions what what's this what's
going to be
you
so however you can do it yeah
[Music]
i'm really worried about making this
thing sturdy enough once we wrap it up
if there's any wind it's going to be
like dorothy and wizard of oz i'm going
to take off i don't think it's going to
withstand any snow loads or hurricane
winds but you know might not die tonight
we'll see what happens all right guys
should we wrap this thing with a hip hip
hippity hop with a bang bang boogie bang
bang a beat
well not too bad
looking pretty good
hey becca should we take a little break
and get some lunch
jacob what game are you playing
you're playing runaway from jacob jacob
goes to his cousin and says do you want
to play a game
he goes what's the game he goes run away
from jacob and then he tries to stab him
with a stick
nathan look what i brought
chick-fil-a sauce
knows how to cook a hot dog oh luke you
don't put ketchup on a hot dog i forgot
oh
my god
i think we're okay i'm not seeing any
leaks starting to dry up the ground i
think this might work
oh
all righty all right guys that's my
cling wrap cabin let's check her out
oh
yeah it's nice and dry in here we are
getting some leaking on the corners the
water's coming down the inside of the
wall on this side every now and then i'm
getting a little bit on this side too so
long as you stay away from the walls
you're okay but the roof doesn't seem to
be leaking at all so that's good news
but i gotta go make dinner for the kids
so i'm just gonna let the rain do its
thing
and we're gonna come back and check the
cot and see if there's any water
droplets on it if there's any water on
the cot when i come back then i'll know
i got a leak in the roof
all right let's see if it leaked
i think we might be okay better go get
my camping stuff
all right we got it all set up
hopefully we won't spray any leaks yeah
oh my gosh it's dry it's dried a little
bit warmer in here huh we're gonna see
how well this thing heats up with a
little propane
you know it's actually getting a little
warm in here with this heater
i think it's going to be kind of cozy in
here tonight
but i think it's time to get dinner
cooked up
so i'm going to go over and start making
some beef stew
oh my nephew and his wife showed up hey
guys welcome to the party thanks
oh yeah be able to get the other sweet
potato cut up
all right the stew is pretty much done
so i'm going to throw some bread dough
into the stew and make dumplings
and there you go the first dumpling did
you see that it's a helicopter
that's dumpling number two
that was a good call hi grandpa but it's
nice it's so warm kind of chilly becca
requested that i make some more
flatbread so uh
we got that going on
you like the flatbread i love the
flatbread especially with honey butter i
like the stew i love this too it's great
yes
michelle you want to see my saran write
cabinet saran wrap cabinet it locks in
freshness it'll double as a greenhouse i
know actually it's like if you wanted to
make a really cheap greenhouse this
would work i mean
it's a 30 roll of saran wrap two by ones
aren't that expensive 30 bucks for the
saran wrap yeah wow i have leftovers i
mean it leaks a little on the walls but
other than that it's good
this is this is all supported by saran
wrap too uh-huh yeah yup saran wrap bed
well there we go you've seen the saran
wrap cabin i am impressed with the saran
wrap cabin that's unique
becky you staying dry yeah i'm doing
great
it's nice just hanging around the
campfire talking drinking lots of hot
chocolate
not too bad
[Music]
[Music]
okay well it is getting late i got to
get ready for bed here
i need to put some bug repellent on
tonight i don't know if you can see it
but there's tons of bugs up in here like
using this ultra on stuff because it
lasts 12 hours so you put it on and
it'll keep you from getting bit all
night long all right guys it's late i
gotta get to bed and uh i think it's
gonna work out okay
[Applause]
well good morning guys
look what i got going on above me
oh that's heavy that's not good
oh my goodness i can't believe how well
that held there was a lot of water up
there
and it wasn't leaking at all
but uh
it's only 6 30. i'm gonna go try to go
get a little more sleep
oh i gotta get up and get the fire
started
tell you what it was noticeably warmer
inside my shelter
there you go
i slept pretty good in that shelter last
night it was uh nice and warm i didn't
get any drips on me
and even though my bed was a bit
narrower than i had a wished it it
worked out pretty well i slept good
now bringing a thousand foot roll of
cling wrap into the woods might not be
the most pragmatic way to build a
shelter but i'll tell you what if you
ever wanted to build a cheap greenhouse
that is a legitimate way of doing it
you could definitely build a greenhouse
for under a hundred dollars good morning
babe how are you doing
i slept in a house made of cling wrap
and she slept with three small children
i'm not sure which of us was roughing it
more
hey boys how you doing three in the
morning we're just trying to protect
them
and a lovely twist my parents are making
breakfast and i don't have to
it's starting to feel like a vacation
that's a lot of bacon you know grandma
and grandpa are taking care of breakfast
the kids seem distracted you know what
we should do
leave yeah let's leave come on
this is a parenting survival hack
breakfast
nice to me because i'm not in that group
should we actually go get our children
let's go get our children uh we'll go
rescue grandma and grandpa
all right well i need to start packing
up and getting everything ready to go
well this turned out to be a pretty good
shelter but i got to give credit to my
friend patrick with the youtube channel
adventure agents him and his son gave me
this idea when they built a gaming cabin
in the woods using cling wrap so it's
pretty cool video i'll put a link in the
video description below if you want to
see that one i think it's time to tear
down the cabin luckily i brought myself
a demolition crew
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well guys did you have a fun campout
yeah
oh that was a good time and hopefully
you guys enjoyed watching it at home
listen if you want to see more camping
videos from the outdoor boys youtube
channel make sure to click subscribe
because we put out new videos every
saturday morning and check out our
camping and adventure playlist i'll put
a link in the video description below
alright see you next saturday guys bye
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching